hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Alex
Robinson of the real mr. rabe of the
real mr. Robbins so today we're gonna
check out the official teaser trailer
number one for London has fallen London
has fallen London has fallen Gerard
Butler returns this is the sequel to
Olympus has fallen mm sure this will be
very original it sucks
securities have originated levels in
anticipation of the bridge - this mural
[Music]
now it's London's turn
I knew Harvey Dent was up to no good
[Music]
not the flag that was kind of nothing I
like some of it though I do okay I know
you can catch Olympus has fallen I
personally didn't really care for that
movie you know it's it's essentially die
hard in the White House this is not die
hard in London it looks like it takes
place over a lot of areas of London
rather as opposed to just this one
specific location if the film has that
level of dark tone that this trailer is
conveying that would be interesting
because I felt like the first one was a
little totally confused on what kind of
like they do want to be a serious
picture didn't want to be an action
picture just off this one teaser alone
if it has a similar tone I feel like it
could work better but in a lot of ways
yet it looks like nothing nothing it
doesn't make me feel like I want to go
to watch it as soon as possible right I
mean it doesn't come out till next year
so I guess there's only so much you can
show in a teaser I lost words cuz I as
you said I didn't see it Olympus has
fallen northern I see white house down
the two White House movies that came out
two years ago oh no it just looks
generic I guess oh yeah I mean they're
not supposed to be the most original
thing I mean cuz Aaron Eckhart is in the
first one he's the president so it
sounds like the president's visiting
some part of London and then in
terrorist attack happens it's just this
guy should not be President no it's not
he should not be President no you get
Harvey Dent how do they often get Harvey
Dent out of the office as soon as
possible you know and then you think if
for not smoking that's true see how we
do that say we did that we'd suddenly
her knife hearts how you segue is a nice
segue [ __ ] and you know draw a
butler he's not really featured in the
trailer but he's cool and all I felt
like we could have I feel like he could
have been cool or after 300 but yeah but
he just he went the romantic comedy yeah
and then he's trying to go back in
action and I mean people really like
Olympus has fallen that's why this is
getting a sequel so who knows maybe
it'll be a solid picture and then maybe
another place will fall I'm kind of
disappointed by the title though London
is falling yeah because the first one
they go they didn't call it White House
has fallen
or America so only call Olympus has
fallen and this one there like London
has fallen they don't have some like
epic title behind it guys can we come up
with a better title than London has
fallen oh no we can't why not shut up
are you selling my girlfriend what yeah
so much time she talks to me oh damn is
good in bed anyway guys if you needed
the channel you can subscribe with the
real rejects you can check out the real
mr. Robinson channel it's a lot of fun
[ __ ] on there and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter and me on
vine because if we get enough followers
we can get more prominent people on this
channel and I could probably get some
any kind of product placement oh yeah I
hear the personal you paying me for work
don't worry though that's true I hear
flashlights are really looking for
sponsorship right now yeah wait what
flashlights hmm companies that make
flashlights yeah I know it does of
course you know what those are you look
like the kind of guy who would know what
that is well we do you have a girlfriend
I do not that's my point that's my point
toto Okafor hey Ryan thing the whole
thing about DJing the [ __ ] doesn't
really work on girls
especially since Sally she's sensitive
and a pacifist okay I don't know what
you're talking about
Toto DJ and the girl works baby baby
baby baby sham responding as I'm talking
matches it's holding me and to me
she knows I'm out here she's what she
can hear me through this vent about
whatever but toto yeah DJ and the [ __ ]
is the best way to go wow wow oh wow and
you give her a little bit of the Shocker
spawn and then you drop that bass boom
boom she want her up the [ __ ] at the
same time while fingering the vagina and
you're not are you gay no okay well you
want finger the vagina I rub the [ __ ] at
the same time but if you're a gay I
would recommend the butthole - that's a
good life lesson out there people mm-hmm